Big data can be characterized by more than the
three V that we mentioned in the previous session.
Those were volume, velocity, and variety. There
are several practical differences as well.
Jules Berman has a book called Principles
of Big Data: Preparing, Sharing,
and Analyzing Complex Information. He lists 10
ways that big data’s different from small data.
The first is goals. Small data is
usually gathered for a specific goal.
Big data on the other hand may have a
goal in mind when it’s first started, but
things can evolve or take unexpected directions.
The second is location. Small data is usually in
one place, and often in a single computer file.
Big data on the other hand can be in multiple
files in multiple servers on computers
in different geographic locations.
Third, the data structure and content. Small
data is usually highly structured like an Excel
spreadsheet, and it has rows and columns of data.
Big data on the other hand can be unstructured,
it can have many formats in files involved across
disciplines, and may link to other resources.
Fourth, data preparation. Small data is usually
prepared by the end user for their own purposes,
but with big data the data is often prepared by
one group of people, analyzed by a second group
of people, and then used by a third group of
people, and they may have different purposes,
and they may have different disciplines.
Fifth, longevity. Small data is usually kept
for a specific amount of time after the project
is over because there’s a clear ending point.
In the academic world it’s maybe five or
seven years and then you can throw it away,
but with big data, each data project,
because it often comes at a great cost,
gets continued into others, and so you have data
in perpetuity, and things are going to stay there
for a very long time. They may be added on to in
terms of new data at the front, or contextual data
of things that occurred beforehand, or additional
variables, or linking up with different files.
So it has a much longer and really uncertain
lifespan compared to a small data set.
The sixth is measurements. Small data is
typically measured with a single protocol
using set units and it’s usually done at the same
time. With big data on the other hand, because you
can have people in very different places, in
very different times, different organizations,
and countries, you may be measuring things using
different protocols, and you may have to do a fair
amount of conversion to get things consistent.
Number seven is reproducibility. Small data sets
can usually be reproduced in their entirety
if something goes wrong in the process. Big
data sets on the other hand, because they come
in so many forms and from different directions,
it may not be possible to start over again if
something’s gone wrong. Usually the best you
can hope to do is to at least identify which
parts of the data project are problematic
and keep those in mind as you work around them.
Number eight is stakes. On small data,
if things go wrong the costs are limited, it’s
not an enormous problem, but with big data,
projects can cost hundreds of millions of dollars,
and losing the data or corrupting the data can
doom the project, possibly even the researcher’s
career or the organization’s existence.
The ninth is what’s called introspection, and what
this means is that the data describes itself in an
important way. With small data, the ideal for
instance is what’s called a triple that’s used
in several programming languages where you say,
first off, the object that is being measured.
In a small data set, things tend to be
well-organized, individual data points
can be identified, and it’s usually clear what
things mean. In a big data set however, because
things can be so complex with many files and many
formats, you may end up with information that is
unidentifiable, unlocatable, or meaningless.
The final characteristic is analysis.
With small data it’s usually possible to analyze
all of the data at once in a single procedure from
a single computer file. With big data however,
because things are so enormous and they’re spread
across lots of different files and servers, you
may have to go through extraction, reviewing,
reduction, normalization, transformation,
and other steps and deal with one part of
the data at a time to make it more manageable,
and then eventually aggregate your results.
So it becomes clear
from this that there’s more than just volume,
and velocity, and variety. There are a number
of practical issues that can make things more
complex with big data than with small data.